[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour cette émission spéciale
de dimanche en politique ici au café de
la poste de velars sur ouche en côte
d'or pour une émission d'une heure en
direct et en public à moins de deux ans
des élections municipales les défections
de mer n'ont jamais été aussi nombreuses
plus de mille élus ont rendu leurs
écharpes depuis 2014
la colère gronde notamment dans les
petites communes les maires non plus la
foi alors d'où vient cette hémorragie
nos petites communes ont-elles malgré
tout un avenir nos territoires ruraux
sont ils les oubliés de la république
on en débat ce dimanche matin dans un
instant je vous présenterai nos invités
mais nous ne serons pas seuls des
témoins des militants des personnes
concernées par ce débat sont avec vous
elle a besoin bonjour bonjour jean
christophe bonjour à tous effectivement
ils vont pouvoir suivre les échanges le
débat devant un écran à mes côtés des
maires ruraux qui nous feront part ou
non de leur sentiment d'impuissance à
mes côtés aussi des citoyens des acteurs
de la vie publique à qui nous
demanderons s'il se sentent délaissés
par l'état par les politiques des grands
émois qu'on a voulu réunir ici pour un
grand débat citoyen c'est une nouveauté
sur france 3 bourgogne on viendra les
voir tout au long de l'émission pour les
faire réagir et ils vont pouvoir à leur
tour interrogé voir interpeller vos
invités jean christophe à tout à l'heure
merci est là on vous retrouve donc dans
un instant pour les premières réactions
et prise de parole autour de vous et
puis vous qui nous regarde et vous
pouvez bien sûr commenter cette émission
avec le hashtag dit mme paul bourgogne
alors nos invités qui ont accepté de
débattre ce dimanche matin en direct
yolaine de courson bonjour vous êtes dit
oui prenez tous un micro vous êtes
député la république en marche de
côte-d'or merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes une ancienne maire dont vous nous
parlerait aussi de cette réalité là
patrice joly bonjour ou sénateur
socialiste de la nièvre président de
l'association nationale nouvelle
ruralité comme sénateur évidemment vous
êtes au contact vous aussi des élus
locaux au quotidien jean-françois farenc
bonjour
vous êtes maire sans étiquette de blanot
fanchone et loire président des maires
ruraux de saône-et-loire merci également
d'être avec nous et puis louis
gentilhomme bonjour quand je ancien
maire vous aussi sans étiquette c'est
souvent le cas d'ailleurs dans les
petites communes on en parlera peut-être
de saint seine sur vingeanne c'est en
côte-d'or et vous avez démissionné en
janvier dernier vous nous direz pourquoi
dans quelques minutes
alors jean françois parent que j'ai
envie de m'adresser à vous au début de
cette émission vous qui êtes président
des maires ruraux de saône et loire a
répliqué maire d'une commune
vous avez entendu le portrait que j'ai
dressé aujourd'hui delà de la situation
tous ces maires qui jette l'épongé
toutes ces difficultés qui s'accumulent
et finalement beaucoup plus de démission
de mr que par le passé est ce que vous
faites le même constat vous dans votre
département
oui exactement nous faisons le même
constat alors on a même compté 1 il ya
eu 17 en saône et loire 17 maires qui
bat qui ne sont qu'éphémères en 2014 qui
ne sont plus maire aujourd'hui
bon il y a quatre ou cinq décès 1 sur
les sur les 17 mai le reste ce sont des
gens qui effectivement ont décidé de
lâcher leur mandat est bon quand vous
les écoutez c'est une une somme de
raison c'est une somme de raison
je vais en citer deux ou trois
rapidement l'intercommunalité est quand
même la manière dont l'intercommunalité
est exercée est souvent un souci parce
que les mères ont l'impression de
simplement d'assister que les décisions
sont prises en amont et de regarder
passer les trains ça c'est un premier
sujet l'empilement des normes est aussi
est aussi un vrai sujet et puis le
transfert de compétences les transferts
de compétences automatique et on en a eu
malheureusement eu encore un exemple
l'été dernier c'est quelque chose qui
est très très mal vécu je parle du
transfert aux assainissements le
l'assemblée a décidé malgré l'avis du
sénat malgré l'avis unanime du sénat
l'assemblée nationale a décidé de
transférer automatiquement cette
compétence communautaire communauté de
communes s'est très mal vécu certains
sont prêts à ce que c'est que compétents
soient transférés et et pourrait en
décider ainsi mais quand c'est fait de
manière automatique caen s'est imposé
c'est quelque chose qui vient qui
décrédibilise un peu plus le
l'intercommunalité
on va écouter yolaine de courson qui est
forcément autour de cette table
représente aussi la la majorité en place
yolaine de courson vous comprenez et
vous avez la même analyse de la
situation des ces maires des petites
communes dont vous avez été oui bien je
comprends très bien ce que dit monsieur
chirac
je comprends qu'ils aient des maires
qu'ils soient fatigués épuisés mais par
ailleurs je ne partage pas complètement
son point de vue forcément il ya des
berges effectivement qui ont fait
beaucoup de vendeurs aussi
donc quand on a fait beaucoup de mandats
après on s'use il ya aussi
le monde change les citoyens change et
effectivement il ya eu la loi nôtre qui
est passé par là pour parler de ce que
dit le ciel français gouvernement mais
bon donc c'est passé par là
effectivement il ya eu des transferts de
compétences mais pourquoi il ya des
transferts de compétences à une
communauté de communes n'ont normalement
les communautés de communes ça sert à
avoir des projets ensemble et à pouvoir
investir ensemble pour arriver à faire
ça réfléchissez les choses en fait le
servir de faciliter certaines choses et
à dire que bon effectivement à l'eau et
l'assainissement
ce gouvernement n'a pas imposé et au
contraire il a laissé un délai jusqu'à
2026 pour que les communes s'organisent
il faut savoir que l'eau et
l'assainissement
c'est un problème dans notre pays sur la
qualité de l'eau par exemple chez moi
dans le châtillonnais faut savoir la
qualité de l'eau n'est pas bonne il faut
savoir aussi que 25 % de l'eau dans
l'est dans les réseaux suis donc l'eau
est un bien commun alors c'est 20 cas
des communes où leur coûte 50 centimes
le mètre cube vous rendez compte
comment peut-on faire les travaux de
réhabilitation en revanche je pense
qu'il faut en parler parce
qu'effectivement il ya des communes qui
gèrent très bien l'euro 1
alors après juste pour 2026 il ya moyen
d'en parler et de voir comment il peut y
avoir des partenariats ou d'aider des
syndicats parce que ça peut aussi ceux
gérés par des syndicats de l'eau 1 c'est
pas obligé que ça parte communauté comme
il ya plusieurs formules eia jusqu'en
2026 pour s'en occuper
donc le fait que les verts soient est
fatigué je comprends pas ce que le les
grands maires de petites communes c'est
vraiment un des mandats les plus
difficiles se connaît vraiment à portée
de main commente le quotidien du citoyen
et c'est ça qui est quand même passionné
en plus alors on va rejoindre elle a
besoin qui est juste à côté de nous
parce que il ya déjà des réactions vous
êtes avec un élu elsa oui peut-être un
contre-exemple jacky vous vous êtes le
maire de cette petite commune de velars
sur ouche ce sentiment d'usure convient
d'évoquer ce que vous l'avez déjà
ressenti vous ah oui je le partage tout
à fait ce qui vient d'être dit par
monsieur varin qui je partage totalement
car en effet il ya un certain nombre
d'éléments qui font qu'aujourd'hui les
maires sur un peu fatigué quelles sont
nos difficultés
les difficultés se sont déjà les baisses
de dotations quand on sait qu'une
commune d'el que villard sur 174 mille
de jeff a perdu 35% en l'espace de cinq
ans c'est quand même énorme ça fait 61
mille euros de moins pour faire des
investissements
alors justement c'est cette équation
c'est faire mieux avec moins vous renier
sur quoi vous en tant que mère m'a
écoutée sur le fonctionnement on essaye
de fonctionner au mieux
nous avons déjà on n'a pas remplacé un
agent des services techniques
bon on est obligé de calculer au jour le
jour à flux tendu est ce que vous avez
déjà songez-vous à rendre votre écharpe
non parce que vis-à-vis des habitants je
considère qu'il faut aller jusqu'au bout
mais il ya des tas d'éléments il ya
l'usure les normes également la lourdeur
administrative la lourdeur
administrative avec la dématérialisation
ou les âges en il ne s'y retrouvent plus
et par manque de formation aussi est ce
qu'il ya des jours où vous vous dites
que des moments où vous dites je ne peux
pas satisfaire mes administrés
c'est vrai oui oui il ya des jours on se
dit on ne peut pas réparer des routes on
ne peut pas apporter ce que les
habitants attendent
et ça on en est
désolé vous allez vous représentez non
non mais bon là j'ai dans la j'avais
décidé bien avant les représenter ils
sont prêts à beaucoup sur presque plus
de plus de 50% à ne pas se représenter
certainement un d'après d'après les
dernières études beaucoup plus nombreux
que par le passé patrice joly on a
entendu les baisses de dotations
je me retourne vers vous le sénateur
socialiste parce que ça fait un moment
que ça dure les baisses de dotations aux
communes et aux collectivités locales ça
ne s'arrête pas mais votre majorité
avoue celle de françois hollande avait
déjà commencé ce mouvement comment vous
expliquer aux maires que on peut trouver
d'autres solutions pour financer parce
que ils ont l'air d'être un peu d'avoir
serré la ceinture très largement et de
plus pouvoir répondre aux attentes de
leurs administrés c'est une réalité les
tensions financières sont réels les
marges de manoeuvre se réduisent
vous avez évoqué les dotations mais il
ya également les contrats aidés qui
était une source importante de moyens
supplémentaires accordés d'accorder aux
communes qui permettait de d'apporter
des réponses à la sur un certain nombre
de services
derrière ça mais je ne partageais déjà
cette critique dans l'ancien sur
l'ancien gouvernement
ça renvoie lotion de la gestion de la
dette publique aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui la question de la dette
publique elle est aussi fonction des
moyens qu'on se donne pour la rembourser
et par e.on est depuis maintenant une
vingtaine d'années dans un dans une
logique politique qui vise à réduire la
part du secteur public et donc à part
des dépenses publiques on peut se poser
la question si c'est une bonne solution
pour répondre aux problèmes de l'eau
territoires ruraux en particulier qu'ont
besoin d'intervention publique de
services publics d'équipements publics
peut-être plus que d'autres territoires
parce qu'il ya des capacités
d'initiative privée je pense en
particulier dans l'est dans les
métropoles
aujourd'hui donc les maires aussi au
delà de ses marges de manoeuvre qui se
réduisent donc des perspectives d'action
qui diminue les maires ont le même état
d'âme que l'ensemble de la population de
l'eau territoire dire le sentiment de ne
pas être reconnu pour ce que nous valons
et pour ce que nous pouvons offrir
également à l'état on a quand même le
sentiment pas simplement sous ce
gouvernement mais depuis 10-15 peut-être
même 20 ans on a le sentiment que
l'avenir de
france mais penser qu'autour des la
perspective et de l'avenir des
métropoles et si l'avenir bien sûr et
c'est vraiment de marge parce que nous
avons beaucoup à offrir un autre pays en
matière de développement et de
redressement jean françois favrat que
cette baisse des dotations avec aussi
cette incertitude de beaucoup de maires
sur la question de la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation qui devrait d'après le
gouvernement je parle sous le contrôle
de courson mais devrait être compensé à
l'euro près il n'empêche que beaucoup de
maires s'inquiètent
cette baisse des dotations est là elle a
quand même un effet important
un maire pourquoi un maire s'engage il
s'engage il sait qu'il va avoir de la
gestion à faire de la gestion courante
de l'entretien de sa commune de
l'entretien de voirie et puis il a aussi
dans l'idée en général avec son équipe
de conduire des projets et pour conduire
des projets il faut des ressources
financières il faut un autofinancement
il ya les subventions mais il faut un
autofinancement et l'effet de cette
baisse des dotations c'est que les que
beaucoup de communes ont n'ont plus de
ressources de pour financer leur projet
pour mettre les 20% qui sont toujours
nécessaires quand on construit un projet
bon si on se débrouille bien on peut
avoir 70 à 80 % de subventions
c'est assez rare 87 assez rare
aujourd'hui mais 70 mais il faut que la
commune m 30
et aujourd'hui si vous avez un budget
avec les baisses de dotations de
fonctionnement vous avez plus donc les
maires se trouvent ils sont plus en
situation de construire des projets par
contre ils ont toujours le quotidien
l'ailé les démarches des citoyens sur le
quotidien donc
donc c'est quelque chose qui contribue à
la halle à la fatigue dont on parle ce
qui les blesse qui les fatigues
c'est justement aussi qu'ils ne peuvent
pas assumer finalement leur programme le
programme électoral pour lequel ils ont
été élus vous le dise oui tout à fait
alors les maires effectivement de notre
association notre association nous avons
240 mère qui sont à l'association des
maires ruraux en saône-et-loire et nous
le dit
ils nous le disent ils ont pas et ils
avaient ils avaient prévu ça peut être
de rénover un bâtiment de de te faire
des investissements pour l'école et ils
ont plus les moyens de
de faire ces projets où il les dit faire
il les dit faire il les dit faire
maintenant beaucoup me disent avant on
pouvait mener deux projets aujourd'hui
on ne peut plus emmener qu'un donc ça
c'est très rare et agir et à entrer en
dialogue avec vous avec elle a besoin
qui est à nouveau à côté de gens qui
souhaitent réagir ici dans ce café de la
poste ne vaut la rue rouge sur wii avec
gérard vous avez vous été élu pendant
très longtemps
vous m'avez interpellé vous aviez
quelque chose à dire oui à propos de
l'eau et de l'assainissement
j'ai un exemple très concret le
gouvernement a voté cette année une
diminution du permis de chasse qui passe
de 400 euros à 200 euros divisé par deux
voilà et personne ne s'est posé la
question de qui allait financer cette
différence la différence elle sera
financée par le consommateur d'eau
puisque l'état a inscrit dans son budget
un prêt loin les un prélèvement de 480
millions d'euros sur les agences de
l'eau et notamment au profit de la
biodiversité et de law and say hello ncc
39 millions d'euros alors louis
gentilhomme et n'est plus maire mais il
est président du syndicat des eaux
avec une particularité c'est que notre
eau arrive de haute marne
donc on a affaire à deux comment deux
préfectures pour gérer notre
problématique de l'eau et jusqu'à
présent pour faire ces travaux puisque
le réseau qui alimente mille abonnés
fait 60 km
donc pour rénover ce réseau qui a une
soixantaine d'années il ne peut pas le
faire sans subvention et c'est les
choses ont changé depuis l'arrivée
d'emmanuel macron pouvoir empire oui
puisque le on nous a supprimé les
agences de l'eau comme elles financent
ce
ces prélèvements enfin qu'elle doive
fines elles sont taxées par ce
prélèvement non plus les moyens de
subventionner les travaux
d'assainissement et sur les réseaux
d'eau gérard vous vous avez jeté
l'épongé en tant qu'adjoint pour quelles
raisons tout à l'heure vous m'avez dit
quand on prépare l émission j'en ai
ras-le-bol l'usure
le fait de ne pas être compris entendus
on nous écoute mais on ne nous entend
pas et on est beaucoup trop faible pour
faire changer les choses
ça ça dure depuis des années où ses
récents non j'ai toujours connu ça en 19
ans de mandat ç'a toujours été comme ça
et on nous on nous écoute poliment mais
on nous ignore
il ya du mépris il ya de la
condescendance
donc c'est assez difficile au bout de
plusieurs années de supporter cet état
qu'est ce que vous allez demander à
violaines de courson la république en
marche vous avez une question pour elle
alors j'ai deux questions alors faire en
sorte que les les présidents de syndicat
d'eau puissent continuer à effectuer les
travaux et au sujet du prélèvement qui
est fait aux communes sur le au profit
du fonds national de garantie
individuelle de ressources qui
garantissent aux communes qui on perde
était perdante avec la réforme de la
taxe professionnelle que ce fng hier
soit remis comme il avait été prévu par
la commission des finances chargé
d'étudier ce dossier une durée de vingt
années au lieu de financer advitam
eternam une un fonds qui bénéficient et
qui bénéficie aux plus gros
on a une envie de transparence si je
résume vos propos par exemple la commune
de saint seine sur vingeanne ses 30000
euros aux parents que l'on donne à ce
fonds donc en huit ans l'a déjà donné
240 mille euros voilà merci pour
alors merci il ya des questions très
techniques dans lequel on peut peut-être
pas rentrer là mais tout à l'heure on
prendra un café avec hélène de courson
pour en savoir plus mais d'un mot
condescendance pas mépris mais pas loin
et puis vraie difficulté avec bats
depuis que c'était manuel macro pouvoir
c'est encore pire j'ai entendu un oui
mais elle a dit que depuis 19 ans
c'était pire je suis exactement dans la
dynamique inverse je pense que on peut
vraiment aller vers du mieux
je suis pas du tout pour la ruralité
gémissante mais pour la réalité
conquérante je pense que je partage avec
mon collègue joli nom là il faut arrêter
avec cette histoire de baisse des
dotations il ya eu des baisses de
dotations 2014 2015 2016 mais ces
baisses de dotations pour les communes
rurales sont arrêtés vous êtes tous les
emplois aidés qui vont qui sont diminués
et qui vont aller en s'affaiblissant
d'ailleurs vous non non non non pas du
tout je peux pas vous laisser dire ça il
ya près de 5000 contrats aidés
d'ailleurs vous faisait partie des rares
députés à l'héroïne qui était pas
vraiment d'accord pour la fin des
employés des centres moi je suis pour
que les emplois aidés débouche sur un
vrai emploi ce qui n'est pas le cas il
ya que 20 % des contrats aidés qui donne
lieu à des véritables emplois donc les
gens ils restent dans un espèce de là
même qui sont dans les contrats aidés ne
veulent plus en est donc aujourd'hui ces
contrats aidés vont être remplacés par
les parcours emploi compétences qui les
personnes qui emploient ces gens là va
être obligé les accompagner dans la
formation est vraiment pour un débouché
vers un emploi donc ça c'est beaucoup
plus important puisque mais aujourd'hui
il a quarante mille de ces parcours
empreint compétences qui ne sont pas
encore utilisés parce que c'est vrai que
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué de former
des gens de les accompagner vers un vrai
emploi que de prendre des contrats aidés
qu'en fait ce sont des espèces de
d'emplois subventionnés par tout le
monde
higuain service dans les petites
communes et vous enseigner car il y en a
encore un petit peu
jean-françois farenc sur les emplois
aidés c'est une des difficultés
aujourd'hui oui
donc il y avait il y avait effectivement
des emplois qui étaient dans l'air dans
les écoles dans l'est où le même temps
parfois parfois dans l'entretien est
alors effectivement on vous dit 20%
simplement
arrivé à transiter vers un vrai emploi
mais vous avez dans la société il faut
aussi admettre de lier reconnaître que
dans la société
vous avez des vous avez un certain
nombre de personnes parce qu'ils n'ont
pas tous les peut-être tous les atouts
qui auront beaucoup de mal à des
arrivées sur un obtenir un emploi normal
et je pense que ces gens là ont droit
aussi à l'emploi donc il faut les faut
les prendre en compte et l'emploi aidé
c'était c'était remettre sur le train du
travail sur le chemin du travail un
certain nombre de personnes qui on peut
avoir un certain nombre de difficultés
qui auraient des difficultés sur un
emploi normal sur un emploi standard il
avait des discussions d'insertion une
réaction de patrice joly sur la question
des employés voulu réagir et puis
ensuite on passera aux lourdeurs
administratives avec louis gentilhomme
qui en sait quelque chose
un aspect humain concernant les emplois
aidés qu'il faut avoir en tête à dire
que sommes confrontés en vis-à-vis à nos
concitoyens que nous connaissons depuis
toujours une qui connaissent une vraie
difficulté
la réponse que l'on pouvait apporter
parfois c'était effectivement ce contrat
aidé qui peuvent permettait de remettre
le pied à l'étrier de quelqu'un qui est
dans notre entourage dans notre
voisinage et ça il faut aussi penser
c'est aujourd'hui les élus se trouve
démuni de cette réponse humaine
immédiate un problème d'une personne
un exemple simple que j'ai en tête c'est
une personne qui a des difficultés
familiales qui sommait abandonné à à
boire qui était en train de plonger
complètement et puis la commune décide
de le prendre et c'est pas toujours
facile de prendre un contre est dit dans
ces cas là parce que le regard des
concitoyens en disant pourquoi celui-ci
plutôt qu'un autre
et puis et puis six mois après je veux
dire que cette personne dans un milieu
professionnel reprend pied petit à petit
et puis et puis reconstruit sa vie
aujourd'hui j'ai cette image en tête une
personne qui effectivement on suit son
chemin personnel et professionnel
parce que monsieur ferrat a dit a pas
d'argent pour faire les projets il faut
savoir que la dtn qui est
donc les subventions qu'ils sont
octroyés par l'état aux communes rurales
elles ont été augmenté de 39% depuis
2014 et ces subventions ne sont pas
toutes utilisées la même chose pour le
fcl qui est pour l'investissement local
enfin les noms sont barbares c'est ça il
ya deux types de subventions qui ne sont
pas utilisés et j'en prends une
troisième qui sont les contrats leader
acquis 100 des contrats européens
en france on les utilise 1 6% et c'est
pour l'écossé pour la ruralité
on les utilise à 6% et là il ya vraiment
yabo ya de l'argent par ailleurs
possible parce qu'il ya une grosse
lourdeurs administratives
elsa à une réaction chez de votre côté
dans ce café de la poste
oui je suis désormais avec sylvain
razzano vous faites partie de la cfdt
sylvain quelles sont les conséquences de
cette de ces baisses de dotations d'état
alors la première donc je suis oui
effectivement secrétaire général de la
cfdt départementale au titre des emplois
publics jeu on couvre le champ notamment
de l'emploi public des territoriaux mais
aussi de l'état donc effectivement la
baisse des dotations c'est un refrain
qu'on entend régulièrement de la part
des employeurs publics et
malheureusement les premiers en en
première ligne sont bien sûr ceux qui
rendent le service public c'est à dire
les employés municipaux donc scellé
vraiment eu quelle raison le terrain bah
c'est eux qui aujourd'hui assure le
service public en local et notamment
dans les petites mairies alors on peut
parler des atsem dans les écoles donc et
on peut parler également des agents
communaux qui sont polyvalents et qui
les gèrent à l'ensemble de des emplois
techniques de la commune se traduit
comment concrète elle concrètement
aujourd'hui quand on me parle de
dotation de baisses de dotations de
fonctionnement le fonctionnement c'est
essentiellement les emplois et
malheureusement en emploi des
contractuels et aujourd'hui c'est les
contractuels qui sont les premiers visés
on a entendu dans la politique du
gouvernement actuel
une favori de favoriser l'emploi
contractuel
aujourd'hui on crée de la misère
aujourd'hui au niveau des dix emplois
publics
et ça c'est une catastrophe pour notre
service public
quels sont les remontées que vous avez
vous du terrain
eh bien écoutez les remontées du terrain
c'est surtout des administrés qui en
face non plus le service public alors à
tort on est en train aujourd'hui de
monter le service public contre le
service le service enfin le privé et
force est de constater que les
administrés disent oui faut moins de
fonctionnaires mais est ce qu'ils sont
prêts à assumer le fait qu'on supprime
de la santé dans les services ruraux
aujourd'hui si on parle de la santé par
exemple je vous donne juste un exemple
comme ça aujourd'hui si on supprime les
emplois dans l'est dans le hot dans le
haut côte d'or par exemple eh bien
finalement quand un service public se
ferme
nous n'avons même pas de priver un côté
c'est à dire qu'il faut en moyenne 8
kilomètres pour trouver un médecin pour
un administré donc dans des zones de
ruralité où les personnels ou les
administrés sont des personnes plutôt
âgées est donc pour eux ça pose un
véritable souci de service public
merci beaucoup merci elsa merci à ceux
qui sont autour de nous de réagir aux
propos de nos invités parmi les invités
qui n'ont pas encore pris la parole
prenez votre micro louis gentilhomme
ancien maire de saint seine sur
vingeanne c'est en côte d'or un peu plus
de 400 habitants si je dis pas de
bêtises elles vont naître en plus mr on
a entendu votre ancien premier adjoint
tout à l'heure vous n'êtes plus mer
depuis le mois de janvier
depuis le 1er janvier et je voulais
évoquer avec vous parce qu'une des
raisons il ya toutes celles qu'on a déjà
évoqué évidemment et sur lesquels vous
pouvez revenir bien sûr mais mais quand
je vous ai appelé la première chose pour
vous inviter à cette émission la
première chose que j'ai ressenti c'est
une forme de lourdeurs administratives à
incroyable c'est à dire que le moine des
efforts la moindre des choses que vous
voulez mettre en place et même si des
fois on peut trouver des crédits mais à
quel prix
il faut des tonnes des tonnes des tonnes
d'investissement et puis de temps et
puis aussi peut-être jambes a beaucoup
d'argent et peut-être aussi vous n'êtes
pas assez formés pour affronter tout ça
je pense que la formation
on la trouve sur le terrain ça c'est
clair mais par contre
les problèmes qu'on rencontre avec
l'administration vous parliez tout à
l'heure des subventions il faut dire
aussi qu'à chaque fois que nous
demandons des subventions on nous
demande de faire un schéma de dons alors
qu'on la fait se fait main que rien n'a
été entrepris
donc il est toujours le même mais on
nous demande de renault de nouveau de
prendre un bureau d'études pour alors
moi je refuse de dépenser de l'argent
inutilement parce que si on me donne des
10000 euros dimension de gens dépensent
déjà 9000 pour le dossier à faire avec
la personne chargée de ce dossier
vous n'avez plus d'argent pour le reste
j'ai via aucune utilité de faire les
travaux
c'était le cas je vais vous dire avec le
département jal gré je pouvais avoir une
d une subvention de 10000 euros pour
mettre des ballons dans viens village
pour le 10000 euros au me demandait un
pataquès pas possible donc l'étude que
j'allais faire faire par le par le
bureau d'études m'écoutait plus faire
que la jument alors vous avez préféré
jeter l'épongé plutôt que de décevoir
vos administrés c'est ça finalement
je suis j'en avais surtout ras-le-bol de
ne pas être entendus écoutés oui vous
avez même écrit alors j'écris j'ai
envoyé ma lettre de démission à monsieur
macro qui m'a personnellement répondre
j'apprécie comme quoi il prend le temps
de répondre oui oui oui
par contre c'est pas le cas très souvent
des ministres qu'il nous dise ah ben oui
on va donner le problème at-elle
est-elle dayraut et puis on vous donnera
une réponse qu'on n'a jamais patrice
joly vous voulez réagir à ce qui était
dit cette lourdeur administrative ses
difficultés
qu'évoque louis gentilhomme c'est quand
même la réalité de beaucoup de maires et
c'est d'ailleurs la première raison pour
laquelle il jette l'épongé souvent c'est
la première qu'il cite
quand on parle de leur démission il ya
la réalité des normes et des langues non
adaptés à la réalité des problèmes posés
théron n'est pas content en tout cas moi
je suis pas contre les normes les normes
c'est le droit le droit c'est ce qui
protège le faible et donc faut être très
attentif à ce qu'on dit mais il ya des
landes qui ne sont pas proportionnés la
réalité du risque et lee a surtout
aujourd'hui les services de l'état qui
n'accompagne plus les collectivités
locales qu'il y encore quelques années
il y avait des services un peu
structurée dans les sous préfectures qui
a porté sur le plan juridique des
conseils il avait les d'aider à les dde
qui accompagnait ce qui fait que les
projets aboutissent est il était partagé
entre le maître d'oeuvre c'est à dire la
collectivité la commune et/ou syndicats
ou autre et puis les services de l'état
et on arrivait ensemble un projet qui
était viable et qui pouvaient être mises
en oeuvre
deuxième élément donc c'est une dinde
est une des difficultés est
effectivement pour les pour les
collectivités la deuxième c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'ingéniérie c'est à dire la
capacité à monter des dossiers et c'est
vrai que la diminution aujourd'hui des
moyens donnés aux collectivités je pense
en particulier aucun doute être commune
fait qu'elle ne dispose pas de
l'ingénierie sur le capacité à avoir du
personnel susceptible de dd à monter les
dossiers qui effectivement parfois sont
d'une exigence qu'il a aussi été est
disproportionnée on gère de l'argent
public
il est logique il y à des procédures
qu'il ya des cadres mais on a
aujourd'hui parfois alors en particulier
s'agissant des fonds européens ou là on
assure de véritable usine à gaz et il
faut qu'on puisse alléger
la prochaine procédure allégée ces
modalités de sollicitations francfort
perdent ils apprennent sur le tas les
maires vous vous avez appris sur le tas
comme on on n'apprend pas à gérer tous
ces dossiers toute cette lourdeur
administrative y a pas d'école pour ça
non il n'ya pas il n'y a pas d'école
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya une tendance
vers plus de technocratie plus d'un
générique est pas toujours nécessaire
vous avez demandé dans des communes
rurales on veut refaire moi c'est le cas
dans ma commune on veut aménager la
place du village mais bon on peut faire
des choses très simplement vous avez des
compétences parfois au sein d'un conseil
municipal vous avez des gens qui sont
capables de faire un plan de l'adulte du
bourg et puis de d'aller voir ensuite la
direction des routes là pour se mettre
d'accord sur les bonnes des limitations
il y avait d'ailleurs on remarque qu'on
peut faire il y avait tout un tout un
bénévolat tout un bénévolat qui fait
économiser de l'argent à l'état tout un
bénévolat qui est qui était exercée dans
l'est dans les communes rurales et qui
disparaît quand avec ces transferts de
compétences on parlait d'eau et
d'assainissement tout à l'heure et vous
nous disiez qu'il faut qu'ils y
effectivement et faire ça bien mais
c'était c'était très bien gérer l'eau et
l'assainissement était très bien géré
vous aviez des des gens qui le matin à
les réparer quand il y avait une
défaillance à la lagune s'était taillé
municipal qu'il qu'il le faisait parfois
de moins en moins vrai aujourd'hui vous
appelez un service technique à distance
qui va commencer par envoyer quelqu'un
pour faire un diagnostic ensuite on va
voir quelle entreprise on peut faire
intervenir
ça coûte plus cher et ça ça coûte cher
et ça sera pas forcément ça prend du
temps ça coûte plus cher ça ça sera pas
forcément mieux gérer du tout elle a
besoin à côté de vous il ya aussi
quelqu'un qui veut réagir sur le champ
ses questions de lourdeurs
administratives dans les petites
communes oui patricia gourmand vous êtes
élu depuis 1995
qu'est-ce que vous inspire le débat bon
c'est vrai que ça fait quatre mandats
donc l'usure non gelée pas parce que
j'aime j'aime ce que je fais c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose
une mission de maire c'est une des plus
belles missions ce qui est ce qui est
lourd aujourd'hui c'est que sais je vais
pas dire chaque matin mais presque
chaque matin nous avons des changements
de lois
quand on voit simplement
l'assainissement depuis je veux dire
quelques quelques années un conte suisse
a quand même pas une seule fois on a pu
dire à la main un moment donné on fait
ça c'est pas possible
le lendemain à points ressortent et
argent ne dit pas je dirais donc
aujourd'hui on n'est même pas très très
sûr de ce qui va arriver et je suis
président du syndicat donc je sais ce
que je veux dire ça c'est une première
sur deuxième chose quand on voit les
dématérialise
a sion dites moi dans une petite commune
alors nous on a de la chance j'ai mille
quatre cents habitants
j'ai une secrétaire donc une dgf qui est
parfaite et je l'en remercie
mais dans une petite commune quand il va
falloir dématérialisée tout ça quand on
voit tout ce qu'il faut acheter les
ordinateurs les formations et tout ce
qui s'ensuit
il ya des communes qui pourront pas le
faire c'est l'instabilité votre
principal problème complètement
on n'est jamais sûr chaque matin comme
je dis il ya quelque chose qui nous
tombe dessus
gentiment mais nous le temps que c'est
une autre façon d'être élu patricia qui
avait du recul
ah oui voilà aujourd'hui je dire s'est
il faut être en éveil de tout on éveille
de tous enfin je pense que mes collègues
qui regarde mais je pense que c'est ça
en éveil de tout tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps alors
en plus on a quand même à gérer quand
même nos habitants et ça on est élu pour
ça et par eux il faut quand même pas
oublier et c'est vrai que quand je vois
depuis que je suis maire là quand on
avait des finances dit on pouvait quand
même c'est à dire compter sur nos
finances
on nous a mis quand même ce qu'on
appelle un pic ce 20 juillet ce que ça
veut dire pour ceux qu'ils connaissent
bien fonds de péréquation intérêts sert
à g bah ça sert à rembourser à aider les
communes qui ne sont pas comme une bonne
gestionnaire
alors ça veut dire en sus non madame de
course je crois que c'est ça ça veut
dire non non non ça veut dire que
quelque part
toutes les communes qui ont vraiment
bien géré et qui ont bien géré et j'en
fais partie
on se retrouve avec des sommes à données
énormes et n'ont donc un moment donné on
nous enlève des dotations mais on nous
remet des choses de ce site
exemple aussi pour des communes et les
intercommunalités reçu un tout à ce que
je disais tout à l'heure on avait la ddt
qui nous aidaient sûr je veux dire les
permis de construire intercommunalité
plus de 15,8 au service commun qui c'est
qui paye les communes donc on fait que
ça et tous les jours et tous les jours
et pour terminer quand on dit par
exemple je dire et je vous entends on a
la possibilité d'avoir des subventions
je reprends ce que vous avez dit je veux
dire fait essayer de faire un dossier je
veux dire pour l'europe
essayez de faire un effet s'y essayer je
s'assure que si vous n'êtes pas si vous
n'avez pas le côté administratif à côté
de vous c'est une usine à gaz
donc très compliqué très compliqué ce
qui fait que la plupart du temps et bien
je m'en parlait là toutes les deux tout
à la quelle la plupart du temps on ne
fait pas ces demandes
c'est trop compliqué donc et encore je
dis encore chez nous on a quand même
j'ai dire une secrétaire qui scelle fait
mais sinon dans les petites communes
c'est pas possible
merci merci on va laisser répondre
yolaine de courson rapidement sur ces
points là il ya juste quelques choses
sur lesquelles je voulais revenir de mes
collègues élus cessé sur les maires
ruraux
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose de très
important c'est le bénévolat des équipes
municipales rurales
ça vient on sait très bien que moi par
exemple j'ai rencontré sur les 343
commune qui est constitué ma
circonscription j'en ai rencontré deux
sens et là dessus je leur ai demandée
évaluée à peu près 20 heures et puis
celle de votre conseil pour le tracteur
de macha pour boucher les trous le sigle
sa bulle quand vous connaissez donc on a
évalué par un point de communes comme
flavigny sur ozerain qui compte 3 100
habitants ces cent mille euros 1 5000
euros par an ces cent mille euros par an
en fait c'est l'algérie qui nous manque
l'ingénierie parce que oui il ya une
place on peut la faire soi même je
comprends ce que vous dites tout à fait
mais il ya des projets comme les projets
européens par exemple qui de par
l'imaginaire est plus importante et les
fonds européens ils sont pas bloquées
par l'europe un faux pas ils sont
bloqués par la france
c'est en france qu'on se débrouille pas
bien la roumanie elle utilise
complètement c'est c'est ses leaders
mais nous on reste coi c'est donc il
faut changer ça pour qu'on puisse
accéder à ces financements pour les
communes rurales le plus facilement
possible
louis gentilhomme a l'air d'acquiescer
oui moi je partage tout à fait l'opinion
qu'elle vient d'émettre
c'est vrai que
des dossiers comme l'europe demande
beaucoup de préparation mais vous aviez
emmanuel macron en face de vous louis
gentil qu'est ce que vous lui
demanderiez au nom de ces maires des
petites communes que vous avez été qu'on
arrête les discussions de bistrot
ah bah ça tombe mal c'est normal on est
dans un vaisseau et qu'on soit efficace
moi c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est
l'efficacité 1 un sujet il ya une
analyse ensuite et a les moyens met en
place et après il ya les exécutions
c'est aussi simple que ça mais en france
on complique les problèmes jean-françois
farenc parmi les démissions la grande
majorité écrasante majorité sont des
maires de petites communes de moins de
2000 habitants 887 sur 1021 une
démission volontaire recensés alors est
ce que le pouvoir en place
mais le précédent aussi on peut dire
presque est un pouvoir des métropoles
des grandes communes finalement oui je
crois que c'est un processus qui vient
d'assez loin et je pense que si on veut
arrêter ça il faut il faut faire
confiance
il faut faire confiance aux équipes
communales et puis il faut réfléchir à
un rôle de ces équipes communales là on
voit bien que quand il ya des élections
les taux de participation sont sont plus
importants dans les communes pour élire
les équipes municipales que pour
d'autres élections
on aura sans doute aux élections
européennes un taux d'absentéisme qui
sera très important
donc là il ya quelque chose là avec ses
équipes communales qui est très
important pour tout simplement
l'équilibré de la société
le maire il s'occupe du vivre ensemble
du vivre ensemble local le maire et son
équipe municipale ce clip du vivre
ensemble et donc il faut faire attention
quand même à enfin il faut arrêter parce
qu on désespère avec les transferts de
compétences les baisses de dotations on
désespère et puis et puis les exemples
eau assainissement du mois de juillet
est très malheureux ça veut dire que ça
n'a pas été compris les députés alors je
sais bien que c'était le 31 juillet ont
voté ce dessaisissement de la commune
les communes avaient la compétence eau
assainissement depuis 200 ans
donc on les a dessaisi on les a dessaisi
je pense que les députés ont pas pris le
temps